we're joined now by infectious disease
expert that's dr celine gander she's
also editor-at-large at the public
health at kaiser health news good to see
you dr gander boy help us sort this all
out there are a lot of people that are
cheering as you saw on the plane saying
it's about time still others are saying
this makes no sense what do you think is
this a good idea to lift the mask at
this time
the cdc had delayed lifting of the mask
mandate on public transportation
including airplanes just for another two
weeks right now we're waiting to see how
this new ba2 variant this newer
subvariant of omicron how that's going
to play out across the country and if it
turns out to be pretty mild the cdc was
planning to let those mandates expire
i i am concerned that we just don't have
quite enough information yet and another
two weeks was really the appropriate
cautious approach here
and what about people that have you know
highly compromised immune systems what
does this mean for them
we are now in a phase of the pandemic
where we have put the onus
entirely on those who are
immunocompromised to protect themselves
that means that we need to make sure
that they have access to high quality
mass the best mass possible so that
would mean either an n95 or a can 95 the
other thing to remember here is that
many immunocompromised people don't even
know they're immunocompromised many
americans are obese and have type 2
diabetes which causes a milder form of
immunocompromise and many americans do
not have
primary care doctors insurance and so
may not have that diagnosis and know
that they should be taking extra
precautions
listen i know we're all sick of wearing
a mask i don't know anybody that likes
to wear a mask the other day i was on a
plane i tried to drink and forgot to
have my mask on that's how you we've
i've gotten to wearing it but do you
think that this ruling should be
appealed or should we all just move on
in your opinion
the real question here is what does this
mean for the cdc's power to reimpose a
masked mandate
say if we have another big surge next
fall or winter or say we have another
pandemic and so i do think you are
likely to see this decision appeal to
preserve those cdc powers for that
what-if scenario
and what do you think about a what-if
scenario because we're still not out of
this don't you think there's still more
to come with this pen with this pandemic
and covet in general
yeah there's certainly more to come we
know that this is a virus that
mutates in fact it's mutating very
rapidly
we will see more variants and we will
see other pandemics after cobin so i i
do think the idea of uh stripping
ourselves of an essential essential tool
and toolbox is a really bad idea i think
we do need to have that option at our
disposal if we do face another crisis
all right dr celine gander we thank you
very much and please know if you want to
wear your mask you can still do that
thank you